[Music]
the last thing we saw in the main
storyline of the division
is that we had finally caught up with
feylau she had just executed president
ellis
and was trying to escape the scene after
claiming that it was the division who
was responsible for his death
so given that we're a little while off
receiving any new content let us
speculate on the future of the story
where does this leave the black tusk
have the remainder of the division
agents gone rogue
and what is natalia sokolova's next move
[Music]
[Music]
before we get into it a quick summary of
where we left off and yes this works on
the fact that feylau wasn't killed in
the final manhunt
after a short fight she was taken down
by the agents while trying to escape on
a helicopter although she was dropped
isaac didn't give us anything of
substance that would confirm her death
but unlike the barden fight it also
didn't announce that she was wounded
either
so there is certainly room for
speculation however like i've said
before
isaac has proven to be easily
manipulated a number of times now
so i'm not overly convinced that what he
says can be relied on anyway
summing up faye's situation she lost his
sister
due to an adequate jtf resource to look
after the settlements
faye captures and interrogates rogue
agent cersei
aaron keener is killed followed shortly
after with faye being found out as rogue
barden schaefer is captured by the
division faye locates prison ellis
and executes him blaming it on the
division
fey is found and taken down by the
division
following this fight a couple of comms
were revealed these were recorded by
faye
and left for roy benitez and paul rhodes
i know you hate me you never trusted me
you probably never liked me and only
moderately tolerated me
it's okay that's okay we didn't have to
be friends
and i know you probably think i'm a
[ __ ] that you would never actually say
that
that's my face at least i think the
reason we never really got along is
we're too similar we're stubborn we care
too much
and frankly we're both pretty guarded
people
we've both lost people and we didn't
deal with that as well as we could have
i guess but
i hope that when i'm done you'll
understand why i did what i had to do
i don't expect you to agree with it but
i hope you understand
i'm not sorry i went down like this but
i'm sorry i couldn't tell you why
hey roy this is hard for me
this is probably the hardest thing i've
ever had to do
you trusted me and i loved you for that
it broke my heart having to keep secrets
like this from you but
i knew i knew if i told you what i was
planning you would try to stop me
and if you tried to stop me there's no
way i could have gone through with any
of it
there's no way i could have interrogated
alicia or met
shafer or gone with him
but i had to do this roy i had to
we were losing we lost the authority we
lost the trust of the people we were
trying to protect
without trust we have nothing it doesn't
matter how many good or bad things we do
if no one trusts you to get the job done
and with schaefer and ellis we lost the
legitimacy we lost the ability to say
we are on mission hell the only one who
agreed we were still on mission was
isaac
i knew what i had to do all i needed was
access and
i couldn't get that unless i joined them
or at least
unless i could make them believe i
joined them
i'm sorry i couldn't tell you why
i'm sorry i had to break your trust like
that
but i hope i i pray you'll forgive me
someday
if you don't i might have to come hot
your ass until you do
loud
there is no reason why she would bother
recording these if she was in fact a
full-blown rogue agent
defecting against the division what
these recordings tell me
is that she has come to the conclusion
that the division is fighting a losing
battle
and that the only chance they had was to
take them down from the inside
faye had become an undercover rogue
agent
so why did faye kill president ellis and
blame his death on the division
faye hasn't lost hope in the government
she still strongly believes in the
division's mission
of saving what remains but over time
watching this determined well-funded new
enemy
and the remaining agents around her
either be killed or turn rogue
joining the black tusk ranks was only a
matter of time before the agency fully
collapsed
the only one left in the government is
corrupt and has joined the other side
the chain of command is broken it was up
to her to take him down
before he was used to bring the general
populace over to their side
faye would go undercover and eliminate
ellis after gaining enough trust to get
close to him
this is our chance to shape history
i couldn't agree more mr president you
said it yourself
somebody has to step up i'm willing to
take on that challenge
if we're going to get this country back
on track
we have to be willing to do things that
won't be
popular i know that you and shaffer had
a rather contentious relationship
i hope our collaboration will be more
efficient i look forward to meeting you
in person
that can be arranged excellent
see you soon mr president
what an [ __ ]
she had to do this alone firstly she
didn't know who she could trust anymore
and though she could like benitez
wouldn't have allowed her to do this on
her own
but she had already lost enough loved
ones and didn't want to be responsible
for more of their deaths on her hands
the reason she blamed alice's death on
the division agents was to keep her
cover from being blown after all
schaefer had been captured but she'd
since learned of the true force behind
the black tusk
and that it was much bigger than they
had originally thought
natalia sokolova was still out there and
while she is still around
the threat to the country will never
disappear
yes it means that the division has now
been burned likely now to be flagged as
a rogue organization
but as there were so few of them left
and the fact that they were only losing
ground to this invading force
it was a sacrifice she had to make plus
she has likely come to the conclusion
that she can't do this alone
she may be able to bring more of them
undercover into the btsu to help her
with the mission
feylau decided that it was up to her to
do what no division agent was able to
and that the only way to do this was to
go rogue join up the black tusk
and take ellis and the rest of this
leadership down from the inside
they had no problems with the fact that
she could die while on this mission
but it would seem that she had
discovered more about the driving force
behind ellis and the black tusk
long before she executed him she
realised that what she had done so far
was only the tip of the iceberg when it
came to stopping these invaders
other than taking her chance and
eliminating the leadership i don't think
she had planned her next steps
and was forced to make some quick
decisions on the fly including the
blaming of alice's murder
and she certainly wasn't expecting to be
captured alive by the division
due to the shd now being labeled as
hostile there is the potential for a
little bit of a rift between the jtf and
the division
fey has been held in an undisclosed
location where she's been interrogated
by an understandably angry elani calso
given kalso's generally less than
flexible demeanor
fey says nothing she has a plan
but it involves her keeping the
undercover situation on a need to know
basis
all faye says is that she wants to talk
to benitez
eventually kalso organizes a meet-up
with benitez although he is jtf
he knows faye better than anyone else if
anyone is going to get her to talk
it's him faye tells him everything
and that this is far bigger than they
could have ever planned for
but that she isn't done and she needs
his help to finish the job
benitez believes her and on top of this
provides her with the means to escape
at this stage the btsu had no idea she'd
been captured
but she couldn't simply walk back in and
join the black tusk ranks
after disappearing for so long she
needed something that would not only
lower the chances of questions being
raised
but something that would bolster her
position into the leadership
benitez further assists her by providing
the location
in the guard schedule of baden schaefer
he would be a ticket back in
on top of this maybe she would be able
to find out what he was doing on coney
island where he was captured
after breaking bad and free faye rejoins
with the black tusk
although natalia sokolova is still
skeptical faye's position with the
organization
has been somewhat elevated however
she was quickly put to the test council
has brought in a number of agents who
after being flagged as rogue after
alice's death
have needed to regroup fortunately this
is what they've been trained for
to be out there with potentially no
support alone
she launches an assault on faye's last
known location
kelso is a stubbornly loyal individual
she fights for what she believes is
right
but she is also quick to react and can
see the world in a somewhat black and
white way
so all she is seeing is an agent who is
once in a prominent position
turning her back on the people faye knew
this
which is why she chose not to tell her
when being held captive
due to the risk of blowing her cover but
at the same time she couldn't exactly
tell her black tusk forces
not to engage the approaching agents
faye manages to organise a secret
meeting with a couple of trusted agents
that she has known since they were
initially activated she brings them in
on a mission
and insists they do their best from the
other side of the conflict
to deter the attacks and save as many
agent lives as possible
for the real battle we'll be coming
later on
as the former shd unofficially appointed
commander
kelso didn't take kindly to her plans
and orders being constantly questioned
and overturned
this led to a division within the
division
the following fights would see rogue
agents come up against rogue agents
bruised battered but certainly not
defeated
khalsa agreed to a meeting with faye
although apprehensive she worked through
her issues with fae and eventually came
to an agreement to stop the attacks
while faye proved what she was intending
to do while working undercover for the
enemy
in time kelso came on board with the
plan and from here
they were able to orchestrate a number
of skirmishes that would solidify fey's
position
together kelso and fey would effectively
control the black tusk operations
one from the opposing side keeping up
the illusion
and the other from within their ranks
with every conflict fay gains more trust
from sokol over
she would also advise kelso on
opportunities to discover intel
and break supply convoys yet faye would
be able to continue taking locations of
interest for circle over
while keeping the collateral damage to a
minimum
over time they would be able to work
towards bringing down natalia's
organization
including her potentially secret force
of super soldiers
the hunters but i think i've gone far
enough with this video and for now
a developer recently talked about the
fact that the division story is far from
conclusion
and although i could be way off the mark
with this i'm thinking we're still to
see a lot more to come
so this was just my thoughts and
possibly hopes of the type of direction
the story could take
plus with the rogue wars before calcium
joins with fae
this could give some actual background
to some sort of last stand type game
mode
in the future though i could be dreaming
a little here
of course faye could have just been
killed in a manhunt and all of this
means nothing at all
regardless i enjoy speculating i'm happy
to keep making these sorts of videos of
this interest
i actually find them really fun to talk
about i literally just go crazy on the
keyboard without too much thought
based on what the story has shown us so
far and joining any dots that i can
my wife and i spend countless hours
discussing weird fanfiction and
speculation ideas on stuff like this
my poor kids i don't look forward to the
day that they realize how nerdy we
actually are
anyway i hope you enjoyed this video and
i'll catch you next one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cheers okay